sur la question extrêmement importante
du congé interdit la parole est un
monsieur jean marie sermier
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
notre ruralité va mal la ruralité
française souffre la crise agricole
frappe les exploitants qui peinent à
vivre du fruit de leur travail
la révision de la liste des communes
défavorisées dans les départements
ruraux comme dans le jura suscite
beaucoup d'inquiétude les jeunes
familles préfèrent s'installer en ville
où les services sont plus nombreux et
les emplois plus facile dans ce contexte
des classes d'école ferme en raison
d'une application stricte et
mathématiques par le ministère de
l'école de l'éducation nationale les
nouveaux services peine arrivé le
déploiement du très haut débit
pourtant indispensables aux entreprises
et aux familles prend du retard sur le
calendrier annoncé par le président de
la république à l'évidence
l'objectif d'une couverture intégrale du
territoire dans les cinq ans ne sera pas
tenu la population vieillissante peine
également à trouver les professionnels
de santé dont elle a besoin et enfin les
élus locaux
ces hommes et ces femmes qui oeuvrent au
service de nos concitoyens avec un
dévouement et une abnégation
ils sont souvent découragés nous sommes
dans la période de préparation des
budgets la baisse des dotations d'état
se poursuit en 2017
contrairement à ce qu'ont écrit ici et
là certes elle est moins forte que l'an
passé mais elles s'ajoutent aux baisses
des trois dernières années pour les
finances d'un village le mouvement est
rude brutale insurmontable les
équilibres budgétaires communaux pour
pouvoir les atteindre
les maires revoit les investissements
qu'ils avaient envisagé au début de leur
mandat réduisant ainsi les commandes à
leurs artisans locaux
monsieur le premier ministre allez vous
entendre le désarroi des élus et des
habitants de nos campagnes
allez-vous instaurer un moratoire sur la
baisse des dotations pour les communes
rurales
merci la parole est à monsieur jean
michel baylet mini d'aménagement du
territoire de la ruralité des collectifs
si monsieur non monsieur le député jean
marie sermier
j'ai envie de vous dire tout ce qui est
excessif est vaine et de surcroît
manifestement vous n'écoutez pas les
questions que pose vos collègues y
compris de l'opposition
il répond ce que j'apporte alors une
fois de plus je vais vous confirmer que
jamais autant n'a été fait pour la
ruralité jamais la ruralité française
n'a été soutenu dans de telles
conditions
comparées entre 2007 et 2012
vous avez réuni 2 comité
interministériel d'aménagement du
territoire
nous avons réuni 3 en 14 mois
nous avons à relever plaît s'il vous
plaît en quatre mesures avec les
financements idoines
nous avons créé les contrat de ruralité
qui remporte un succès tout à fait
considérable samson et la signer at sans
avoir de signature
concernant l'école rurale 200 postes ont
été créés par le ministère de
l'éducation nationale
nous avons augmenté la detr de 62 pour
ça elle est désormais d'un milliard
d'euros nous avons augmenté la dsr de
28%
elle est désormais le milliard 350 nous
avons créé le fonds de soutien à
l'investissement local en 2016 1
milliards en 2010 en 2010 7,1 milliards
c'est à dire que nous avons mis les
moyens et nous avons accompagné les
ruraux pour qu'ils puissent en fait
mener les politiques
effectivement que mérite la ruralité
voilà donc une véritable politique
directoire voilà le vrai soutien et
ruralité
voilà ce que fait ce gouvernement c'est
tout le contraire de sonde de ce que
vous n'avez fait car vous n'avez jamais
été pour la vie ratner 6